[Musique]
à l'espace philippe noiret dans la ville
de les clayes-sous-bois nous avons des
films pour les enfants pour les vacances
comme royal corgis la princesse des
glaces dumbo ou encore le parc des
merveilles
nous avons également des films plus pour
les grands comme santiago italia ou bien
victor et célia est seul à mon mariage
le plus fort de tout ça assez avengers
que nous attendions tous le 22e opus de
la saga univers du l'univers
cinématographique de marvel 10 11 ans de
films le dernier opus nous présente nos
super héros dans leurs sentiments les
plus humains qu'il soit possible et
clôture du coup sûr une super saga dont
on peut voir le thanos qui a conquis le
monde avec cgem et les nos super héros
reviennent avec iron man black widow
avec hartmann là il ya les gardiens de
la galaxie
tous vont s'allier contre thanos pour
récupérer la main des gènes on revient
du coup en arrière dans les précédents
opus pour voir comment affronter thanos
et récupérer les gemmes afin qu' il
puisse sauver le monde
[Musique]